your holiness what has the Nobel Prize
meant to you this actually I think
source of inspiration for many people
and particularly those people who
passing through different period and
then also I think some kind of
recognition great sort of significant
contribution in different fields so it
is a source of encouragement
perhaps I also received Nobel Peace
Prize so maybe too much velocity prone
over the position field so indeed a
great honor
have this opportunity visit yeah
from distance
we always admire the body nori
yeah no I think a few occasion I visited
now this time yeah
thank you very much or identity is a the
one chocolate with versatile mobile
picture so I told them I want to keep
that as a souvenir have a deaf consumer
thank you very much